welcome back to
820 special relativity
so in this section we want to look again
at collisions
and study momentum conservation
and so we have this scenario here in
which we have you know two balls
colliding with velocities u a and u b
masses m a and m
and after the collisions there the
masses change to m c and m d and the
velocities are u c and u d
the
random conservation tells you that the
product of the mars and velocities
and the sum of the two particles before
and after the collisions is the same
but now what happens if we boost the
system if we
look at the very same system with a
boosted reference frame
um you know and we can just
you know simplify the case here by just
considering the x direction
so the question is if momentum is
conserved in a frame s
like the one we are looking here in this
picture
is the momentum also conserved in a
moving reference frame
with the relative velocity uh uh v
and so you can show this quite easily
that this is actually not the case right
so you write down the velocities
um
the momentum equation the same equation
as before with boosted velocities and
you find that this is not the case you
can easily show this by for example you
know setting the right part of this
equation to zero
and see
whether or not this this equation will
hold true in general and it doesn't
but
in the last section we introduced the
new concept of proper velocity
so how about
redefining momentum through proper
velocity
and just saying
m a times proper velocity a plus m b
times proper velocity b
is equal to m c
times over velocity c and so on
and see whether or not we can learn
something from this equation
so why don't we write down this very
same equation and with proper velocity
and see whether or not it's invariant in
the lawrence transformation
okay again a good moment to stop the
video and just work out the mass by
yourself on your own
so i did this here
and i'm just doing this for the x
component so we have our proper velocity
vector which is gamma times z
gamma times ux gamma times u y and gamma
times uz
so the x component is the first
component
and
in the boosted reference frame
the
proper velocity of the x component in
our boosters frame is gamma times
the proper velocity of the particle a
first component minus beta proper
velocity of a zeroth component
and so then you can write your equation
and this should be our momentum energy
momentum conservation equation
okay and the loans transformation we
find this one here
and so all we need to do now in order to
show that this is always true or true in
general is to
re-assign relabel
the reorder the individual terms and i
did this here um to make this visible
you see
everything behind in this bracket behind
the better is equal to the equation we
had before there's a minus sign in
between which means it's zero and
everything we see on the top for the
first component
is also b0 that's for the boosted
reference right so we see here and i
just showed this for the x component you
can show the for all component that
momentum is conserved